có sao hội thiếu nêm tin thì chỉ phi phát triển rất lớn
thì khi đúng được vào vệ kétốt được cửu người yếu thế không bị bình hộ lại, vì sao?
người đã m làm bị tốt không cảm thấy có đơn
thì nêm tin sao hội được c控 cố
và nêm tin chỉ là ngồi lực rất quan trọng
phát triển
bởi đến nớt nhất là tổng vội tài tê hẹn này
vì vậy
cân nhìn sự tự tế không chỉ là phòng chất đạo đất cán nhận
sự tự tế còn lượng vốn của xa hội
là sự mạnh của phán ngoài
là mất phần nêm tài của mất phúc xa phần nêm
người tự tế không chỉ biết thương người
mà còn biết sống của chắc nhận
không chỉ biết giúp lợi mà còn biết tôn chọng lợi phát lẽ phái
và phòng là khóng người
không chỉ là một điều tốt khi thuật lợi mà còn giữ được miếng cách
trong khó khám xong thích thích
và trong ngoại cảm giống
chúng ta phải đấu
và đời tự tế
càng rang hỏa tự tế
càng nhẹ tự tế
đã sống đại một
vốn vốn tự tế
là gạng xa hội tự tế
vì điều này
vốn cùng quan trang
một cảm ph市 modo tự tế
để làm người tật tự
với ra con tâm mất cánh trong khó khó biện
không lợi dụ
của lực
để mùi cầu lợi ý riêng
một doanh nhân tự tế là người làm đầu chính gáng
kinh doanh relationship chính
của chắc nhận một raui mua chường
một giỏa tự tế không chỉ l Rouge xin tụ
Chí thức mà còn giang nhân cách xác vọng và lòng nhé nãy cho học trao.
Bác sĩ từ tế không chỉ là chức bệnh kýu người mà còn trong sốc người bệnh bảo í đức sự tập tâm nhắc chắc là.
Bộn người chạy từ tế không chỉ có năng lực kệ chang mà còn có lý đường có miền.
Bộ con sinh từ tế không chỉ sống trong mình, bộng bích chia sẻ với cộn đồng mà vẻ điều đúng không thể ở chỗ kia xanh kìa số kia.